okay the final classification method
we'll we'll talk about in today's lab is
kar's neighbors and although different
classifier to LDA and qda in terms of
using SK learn it's it's quite similar
so the difference is um really in the
actual method we're going to use that's
this first class we call from Psych
learn it's the K's neighbors class we
construct a classifier using the one
nearest neighbor the rest of the code
where we fit and predict on training fit
on training predictor test uh is
identical and again compute the
confusion Matrix so we see here that
using one nearest Neighbors which is
going to be a very flexible uh
classifier so like possibly having high
variant um it may suffer from
overfitting and indeed um the classifier
is not very good it has about 50% um
test accuracy as bad as you can get yes
okay let's see if we um change the
number of neighbors if we do and be
better using three neighbors uh we get
about 53% which is better but not quite
as good as the discriminant methods we
saw before so the these K nearest
neighbored methods are extremely
adaptive and flexible but they can
overfit especially you know on small
data sets yes so it would be nice to be
able to choose this using in a simple
fashion that's and that's what we'll do
next so we're going to use a slightly
different data set um this is the
Caravan data set uh from the islp
package which uh talks about whether we
can predict whether people purchase uh
Caravan insurance or not um and it's
noted it's a very imbalanced
classification problem because there's
only 6% that actually do purchase unlike
the stock market data where uh the up or
down is going to be roughly 50% if it's
if it's basically noise in case you
didn't know a caravan is a Campo van in
Australia and New Zealand and South
Africa and
other colonies and I guess it would be
an RV in in North
America okay so um we'll just create you
know we'll use all of the features uh
besides the purchase column to create
some
features and
now unlike this the stock market data
where we just had lag one and lag two
was our features it turns out there are
many different features in this Caravan
that are you know measured in slightly
different units so uh since the canorous
neighbors classifier uses distances
between points if one variable is much
has very different units than another
variable it will tend to dominate the
distance so for that reason we're going
to use um we're going to standardize the
features before you classifying so for
that we'll use the a scaler or the
standard scaler from Sid learn and this
is an example of a transformer we saw
Transformers um uh when in chapter three
in linear regression when we in the
model spec that was an example of a
transformer and if you remember the
Transformer it's something that we
mentioned is used to sort of create
derive features from existing features
that's a typical application so we apply
we call it fit method on a set of
features notice there's no there's just
the set of features in this fit method
not a response because it's taking
features to create new features and
having fit the Transformer that finds
all the parameters in this case the
means and variances needed to scale the
features to variant to mean zero and
variance one then we can apply it to the
features using the transform
method okay so we'll use our
standardized features for K
neighbors um and we'll also do a a split
into test and training and we'll use the
the test data to
um with various different neighbor sizes
to try and choose a uh a good number of
neighbors okay so this is just like the
stock market kar's neighbors example
except of course we have different data
this is the Caravan data and not the the
stock market data we see with uh one one
nearest neighbor
um it actually we get about 11% accuracy
which is you know better than 6% 6% is
what we would get if we had no a
reasonable estimate of what we' get if
we had no features if we just Ed an
Intercept in the model so we see some
improvement um but not always uh not a
great
Improvement okay so let's talk about
choosing the number of near near
neighbors this is an example of choosing
a tuning parameter for an estimator a
common task that we'll see in other
examples coming up um so what we're
going to do is
um fit Thea the the caners neighbor
classifier for varying numbers of
neighbors and we're going to choose
neighbor Neighbors from uh here we
WR we have a four Loop and we're going
to Loop over the the neighbors 1 to five
and just in case you're well that's the
range 1 to six actually really gives us
only the numbers 1 to five that's how
the range function works okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to
within the for Loop do essentially what
we had done above that is we're going to
uh fit on the training data predict on
the test data and form the confusion
Matrix and then we'll compute the
accuracy and we're just going to print
out uh with this statement here print
out the accuracy as a function of
nearest Neighbors in later Labs will'll
make a plot of uh accuracy or um mean
squ eror as a function of tuning
parameter here we're just going to print
it
out
okay um and so one small thing that you
if you noticed earlier took us three
lines to form the confusion Matrix uh we
avoid to a line by looking at the fit
predictor and directly calling it
predict method uh it's only two lines to
to fit and form the confusion
Matrix okay so let's see
um for this test and training split we
can see um most of the number of
neighbors achieve around 14 or 15%
accuracy with four neighbors being a
kind of anomaly that um we haven't
really investigated but it is a notable
difference uh between the other ones it
only predicted fourward rent yes so it
it was strange and you can get this with
nearest neighbors because it's a very
noisy classifier
yes okay so that that wraps up what we
were going to talk about in in the lab
today there are a few more sections in
the lab that we encourage you to go
through uh one including poon regression
um that we will leave to you to do
offline